so many people out there i'm gonna been
given a list now how about chris or the
associated press
first question
so you've warned about the real threat
of chemical weapons being used have you
gathered specific intelligence that
suggests that president putin is
deploying these weapons moving them to
position or considering their use and
would the u.s or nato respond with
military action if he did use chemical
weapons you know on the first question i
can't answer that i'm not going to give
you intelligence data number one number
two
we would respond we would respond if he
uses it the nature of the response would
depend on the nature of the use
uh
josh of bloomberg
perhaps i'll just project mr president
uh thank you very much i fired your
voice i haven't been elected a lot
earlier i'll give it a try he's got a
long arm thank you uh can you uh talk to
us about two things sir once since your
conversation with president xi of china
have you seen any indications of action
or lack of action from china that has
led you to believe whether they will
intervene and help russia either with
the sale of arms or or the provision of
supplies to support this war in ukraine
and secondly uh can you say whether this
the conversation today turned to the
subject of food shortages and what the
u.s will do to address wheat shortages
in particular as a result of this war
thank you on the first question relating
to uh president xi jinping of china
i had a a very straightforward
conversation with
she
now i guess it's six days ago seven days
ago in that range
and uh
i
made it clear to him i made no threats
but i made it clear to him
that make sure he understood the
consequences of him helping russia as
had been reported and as as what was
expected
and uh
i made no threats but i pointed out the
number of
american and foreign corporations left
russia as a consequence of their
barbaric behavior
and i indicated that
i knew how much he because we had long
discussions in the past
about his interest in making sure he had
economic relations and economic growth
with europe and the united states
and indicated that he'd be putting
himself in significant jeopardy and
those
in those aims if in fact he were to move
forward
i
am not going to comment on any detail
about what we know or don't know
as a consequence of that conversation
but uh
tomorrow is
tomorrow or next monday that ursula's
having that conference with china
the first
on on april 1st we've had discussions
because i think that
china understands that
its economic future is much more closely
tied
to the west
than it is to russia
and so i i i'm hopeful
that he uh
he does not get engaged
we also did discuss today
that there's a need for us to set up
nato to set up and and the eu
to set up a system whereby we have an
organization looking at
who has violated any of these sanctions
and where and when and how they violated
them
and that's something we're going to put
in train it's not done yet
so with regard to
she i
i have not nothing more to report with
regard to food shortage yes we did we
talked about food shortages
and uh and it's going to be real the the
price of these sanctions is not just
imposed upon russia it's imposed upon an
awful lot of countries as well including
european countries in our country as
well
and because both
russia and ukraine
have been the breadbasket of europe in
terms of wheat for example just give you
one example
but we had a long discussion uh in the
g7
with
the
with both
the united states which has a
significant the third largest producer
of wheat in the world
as well as canada which is also a major
major producer
and we both talked about how we could
increase and disseminate more rapidly
food shortages in addition to that
we talked about
uh urging all the european countries and
everyone else to end trade
restrictions on
on sending
limitations on sending food abroad
and so we are in the process of working
out with our european friends
what it would be what it would take to
help alleviate the concerns relative to
food shortages we also talked about
a significant major u.s investment among
others in terms of providing for
the need for
humanitarian assistance including food
as we move forward
um
uh tarina of the wall street journal
watch out you know you're hitting the
head there now
mr president in your view does president
zielinski need to cede any ukrainian
territory in order to gain a ceasefire
with russia or is that completely off
the table and then also do you think
that russia needs to be removed from the
g20
on the latter point my answer is yes
that depends on the g20
um i
that was raised today and uh
i raised the possibility if that can't
be done if indonesia and others do not
agree
then we should in my view
ask to have
both uh
um ukraine
uh be able to attend the meetings
as well as uh
um well
basically ukraine being able to attend
the g20 meeting and observe
with regard to what was the first
question
that is a total judgment based on
ukraine
nothing about ukraine without ukraine
i don't believe that they're going to
have to do that but that's a judgment
there's negotiations that are
discussions i should say
that have taken place that i have not
been part of including ukrainians
and it's uh it's it's their judgment to
make
um
cecilia abc
there you are
oh
thank you
sir you've made it very clear in this
conflict that you do not want to see
world war iii but is it possible that in
expressing that so early that you were
too quick to rule out direct military
intervention in this war could putin
have been emboldened knowing that you
are not going to get involved directly
in this conflict
no one no
and to clarify on chemical weapons could
if chemical weapons were used in ukraine
would that trigger a military spot
response from nato
it would be it would trigger a response
in kind whether or not you're asking
whether nato would cross
we'd make that decision at the time my
final question because you're heading to
poland tomorrow do you think that
getting a first-hand look at the effects
of this war
on these millions of ukrainians who have
fled their country could change the way
that you might respond
i don't think so because i've been to
many many war zones
i've been in
refugee camps i've been in war zones for
the last 15 years and it's it's it's
devastating and uh but the thing you
look at the most is you see these young
children
you see children without parents that
are in those camps or in
refugees you see women and husbands and
men and women who are completely lost
and have no nose you see the look that
blank look on their face
that absolute feeling of my god where am
i what's going to happen to me
and so
it what it will do it will reinforce my
commitment to have the united states
make sure we are a major piece
of dealing with the relocation of all
those folks as well as humanitarian
assistance needed both inside ukraine
and outside ukraine for example this is
not something
that poland or romania or germany should
carry on their own
this is an international responsibility
the united states is the leader one of
the leaders in the international
community has an obligation to be
engaged to be engaged and do all we can
to ease the suffering and pain of
innocent women and children and men for
that matter throughout throughout
ukraine
and those who have made it across the
border i plan on attempting to see those
folks as well as i hope i'm going to be
able to see
i guess i'm not supposed to say where
i'm going am i
but anyway i hope i get to see
a lot of people
um
marcus or der spiegel
thanks mr president
um
there isn't a presidential election
coming up in 2024 and as you know there
are white yes
that's true
and there are widespread concerns in
europe that um a figure like your
predecessor maybe even your predecessor
himself might get elected president
again
um so are there any steps anything
you are trying to do and nato is trying
to do here these days
to prevent
what you're trying to do becoming undone
two years from now thank you no
that's not how i think of this i've been
dealing with foreign policy for longer
than anybody is involved in this process
right now i have no concerns about
the impact i made a commitment when i
ran this time
i wasn't going to run again and i mean
that sincerely i had no intention of
running for president again
and uh until i saw
those folks coming out of the fields in
virginia carrying torches and carrying
nazi banners and literally
singing the same
vile
rhyme that they used in germany in the
early 20s or 30s i should say
and um
and then when
the gentleman you mentioned was asked
what he thought and a young woman was
killed a protester
and he asked was asked what he thought
he said they're very good people on both
sides
and that's when i decided i wasn't going
to be quiet any longer
and
when i ran this time and i think the
american press whether they look at me
favorably or unfavorable acknowledge
this i made a determination
nothing is worth
no election is worth my not doing
exactly what i think is the right thing
not a joke
i'm too long on the tooth to fool with
this any longer
and so
we're a long way off in elections a long
way off
my focus of any election is on making
sure that we retain the house in the
united states senate
so that i have the room to continue to
do the things that i've been able to do
in terms of grow the economy and deal
in a rational way with american foreign
policy and
lead the world
lead be the leader of the free world so
uh um but it's not a it's not a logical
question for someone to ask
i say to people at home
imagine if we sat and watched the
doors of the bundestag broken down and
police officers killed and hundreds of
people storming in or imagine if we saw
that happening in the british parliament
or whatever how would we feel
and uh
one of the things that i take some
solace from
is i don't think you'll find any
european leader
who
thinks that
i am not up to the job
um and i mean that sincerely it's not
like whoa it's that's that
the point is that when the first g7
meeting i attended like the one i did
today
was in great britain and i sat down and
i said america's back
and one of the one of my counterparts
colleagues as head of state said for how
long
for how long
and so i don't blame i don't i don't
criticize anybody for asking that
question
but uh
the next election i'd be very fortunate
if i had
that same man running against me thank
you very very much mr president
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa
no yeah one final question right hey
little way hold on a second please
i was supposed to be an hour ago at the
european union meeting and to speak now
i'm thanking you
uh so says i'm gonna haven't called on
before
you
who are you
okay
sir deterrence didn't work
what makes you think vladimir putin will
alter course based on the action you've
taken today let's get something straight
you remember if you covered me from the
very beginning i did not say that in
fact the sanctions would deter him
sanctions never deter
you keep talking about that
sanctions never deter
the maintenance of sanctions
the maintenance of sanctions the
increasing the pain and the
demonstration why i asked for this nato
meeting today is to be sure
that after a month we will sustain what
we're doing not just next month the
following month but for the remainder of
this entire year that's what will stop
him
that's not what i said
you're playing a game with me i know the
answer is no
i think what happens is we have to
demonstrate the purpose the single most
important thing is for us to stay
unified
and the world continue to focus on what
a brute this guy is and all the innocent
people's lives are being lost and ruined
and what's going on
that's the important thing but look if
you're putin
and you think that the that europe is
going to crack
in a month or six weeks or two months
why not
they can take anything for another month
but we have to demonstrate the reason i
ask for the meeting we have to stay
fully totally thoroughly united thank
you
[Music]
if
if
if we can have everyone stay seated
we could have everyone stay seated
we could have everyone stay seated until
the traveling package is departed
oh i'm so sorry
okay
thank you
you